dieser roboter soll echt alles können
schwimmen fliegen rollen und sogar
tauchen das geheimnis des transformer
roboters er kann seine form und somit
auch seine fähigkeiten verändern
die nasa möchte mit diesem prototypen
namens shape shifter den geheimnissen
unerforschter himmelskörper auf die
schliche kommen wie zb dem mysteriösen
saturnmond titan und der roboter hat
dafür wirklich extreme fähigkeiten krieg
zum science fiction gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
derzeit tüfteln asa forschungsteams an
einem prototypen mit dem namen shape
shifter übersetzt also so viel wie
formwandler und der macht seinem namen
wirklich alle ehre
tatsächlich erinnert er ein wenig an die
vom wandelnden roboter die transformer
die man bislang nur aus science fiction
story scannt der plan der nase hat es
aber in sich denn der shape shifter soll
seine form und somit auch seine
funktionen verändern können somit kann
er sich an seine jeweilige
forschungsumgebung anpassen und diese
bestmöglich erkunden
je nachdem in welchem thema sich der
transformer roboter also bewegt kann er
tauchen schwimmen fliegen oder rollen
super wichtige voraussetzung um
beispielsweise den titanen zu erkunden
das ist der grösste saturnmond der in
einigen aspekten der erde ziemlich
ähnlich ist die sonde cassini ist
bereits an ihm vorbeigeflogen und konnte
seine oberfläche kartieren
auf ihm befinden sich sehen höhlen
vulkane inseln und canyons dennoch gibt
es viele ungeklärte fragen über diesen
saturn man beispielsweise in bezug auf
den exotischen kreislauf von
kohlenwasserstoffen wie e tan und metern
die hier mal als eis oder gas oder aber
als flüssigkeit zirkulieren und nicht
nur das die vulkane auf diesen monaten
keine lover sondern ammoniak auch die
titanischen gewässer sind für die
fachwelt noch ein großes rätsel
dazu der nasa-forscher aliaga wir haben
nur sehr begrenzte informationen über
die zusammensetzung der oberfläche
felsiges gelände mitansehen creo vulkane
das alles gibt es dort möglicherweise
aber wir wissen es nicht genau
also haben wir darüber nachgedacht wie
wir ein system schaffen können das
vielseitig und in der lage
verschiedene gelände typen zu
durchqueren dass aber auch raum hat
genug ist um mit einer rakete zu starten
er plant der nasa zielt darauf ab kleine
wandelbare roboter zu entwickeln die den
titan und seine sehen erforschen die
erkundungs geräte sollen sich
letztendlich ganz von alleine zusammen
und wieder auseinander bauen können ohne
dass sie dabei anweisungen von der erde
benötigen zusammenarbeiten sollen die
wandelbaren roboter mit einem rover der
als energiespeicher funktionieren könnte
hier könnten sich die transformer
roboter aufladen zudem soll dieser
länder nach plan der nasa auch mit
wissenschaftlichen instrumenten
ausgestattet sein um proben aus zu
werden falls eine region erkundet werden
soll zudem der rover es aus eigener
kraft nicht schafft könnten sich zehn
roboter zusammenschließen
ihre basis an diesen schwer erreichbaren
ort zu fliegen eine super coole sache
denn so wäre der rover nicht an eine
bestimmte region gebunden die nasa
beschreibt den derzeitigen prototypen
als eine vorrichtung die aussieht wie
eine drohne die in einem länglichen
hamsterrad eingeschlossen ist so kann
sich der chef shifter rollend
fortbewegen doch dabei handelt es sich
genau genommen nicht um einen roboter zu
solch einem hamsterrad
zusammengeschlossen haben sich nämlich
zwei multi copter der zylindrische käfig
besteht aus zwei hälften zwei drohnen
also die gemeinsamen rollen können und
doch ist jede für sich allein flugfähig
die vorteile liegen auf der hand
hindernisse können einfach umflogen
werden und auch große distanzen sind
fliegend schneller zurückzulegen fahren
beziehungsweise rollen ließ dagegen
energieeffizienter der plan der nasa
sieht aber noch mehr funktionen vor
mehrere roboter können auch als
schwammen die oberfläche eines
himmelskörper seinen kunden mit einem
propeller ausgestattet könnten sie aber
auch unzugängliche höhlen erkunden als
kette könnten sie dabei sogar die
kommunikation mit der oberfläche
gewährleisten als kugel
zusammengeschlossen könnten die roboter
aber nicht nur rollen sondern auch als
eine art bot mysteriöse sehen aus methan
erkunden bisher existiert ein 3d
gedruckter prototyp namens shape shifter
dieses lhasa projekt gehört zum
sogenannten innovationsprogramm nasa
innovatives konzept und somit ist nicht
klar wann dieses projekt für eine echte
mission ausgewählt wird fest steht aber
schon die nächste mission zum titan soll
im jahr 2026 statt
hier wird wohl der fliegende robert
drechsler eingesetzt um den spannenden
geheimnissen des atoms auf die schliche
zu kommen wie roboter uns in zukunft
helfen anklicken also hier anschauen und
doktor watson unbedingt abonnieren super
kanal bis dann bleibt dran